you know you're not going to get a
refund if you end up sitting next to you
know fat people say you can yes say it
dude fat people oh what a dick boom
[Music]
boom
all right this one's gonna be a little
difficult because uh it's going around
the internet everyone's weighing in on
their opinions uh we need to figure out
what we think about this because we've
probably all been in a situation very
similar
there was a woman on American Airlines
uh who was on a flight and now she's
demanding reparations because she had to
sit in between two obese passengers and
it was so sandwiched in why she gotta
say reparations you're gonna say a
refund I made choice of words this
really matters does it I
she literally did say reparations that's
odd so here's a picture of like I know
it looks like the same side but I guess
they're mirrored or switched around but
that's her uh which one is she she's the
one the red no not the one the red yeah
she's in the red so that's her arm and
she's saying that like they're so packed
in like this and they weren't the
airline wasn't really doing anything to
help her situation she couldn't put her
tray down because there it was hitting
him in the stomachs
um and uh she had asked them though so
the people that are sitting to her left
and right are siblings and she's like do
you guys want to sit next to each other
I can switch with you and they were like
no it's cool so then she's just
sandwiched like this the whole time
she's taking pictures and uh
she went off yeah she went on this huge
tirade on Twitter sounds annoying dude
talking about how um and she's she's not
backing down she's like really the
flight was three hours
um I don't know how long it's like just
lean forward yeah look it sucks
obviously it sucks listen here's what
she said she goes I'm expected to have
only a quarter of a seat when I fly I
just experienced getting sweat on Touch
without my consent smacked in the face
and subjected to hours of no personal
space and your response is essentially
too bad well that's what they said
that's what she's saying oh and she's
saying that uh that I was called that uh
she the polite attendant was like
looking at her and just giving her like
a
like one of
them what can they really do yeah this
that's why she said she said that hey if
you want to
I think that you should buy another seat
that's her I feel like the airlines
would get in trouble if they were like
oh you two need to move because you're
too fat it would yeah or are you gonna
buy two tickets yeah you know what this
means she's she's good she's due for
some good like airplane Karma next time
she flies she's probably gonna get an
empty seat next to her sometimes it
happens and listen oh okay you you fly
next to a really big dude with big old
leg like the last time I flew back this
guy was he was like he was probably like
six three and he was a big [ __ ] boy
dude he was a big and he was like all up
in my [ __ ] so you know what you do is I
yeah he was like all up on me and then I
just fell asleep kind of like [ __ ] it's
a free pillow bonded yeah we bonded and
I was like you know what because this
dude was like taking my leg room and I
was like I can't be a [ __ ] dude I can't
be sitting with my knees like this so
then I kind of pretended to fall asleep
and then I actually fell asleep but I
kind of fell asleep over here and then
eventually he kind of moved his body
into the aisle but on the way there that
was on my way back on the way there I
got a free seat we had two [ __ ] seats
on my phone and have never had anybody
next to me nice every time every single
time I've only flown like five times
though would you fly a Southwest uh
Southwest amazing American and Alaska
that's because people are looking at you
like I'm not trying to sit next to no
personal space I always sit by the
window and then I kind of make myself
bigger talking to yourself and [ __ ] too
you said Sumo yeah
because I don't want anybody sitting
next to me the uh so she said the also
she couldn't put the armrest down
because they were just like stuck there
obviously and uh her another famous
quote she said I'm sick of acting like
fatness to this extent is normal oh my
gosh she's sick she's going hard yeah
what airlines was this American Airlines
yeah oh so you do buy the seat because I
think Southwest right yeah it's wherever
you go yeah do that that's just bad luck
dude that's just bad luck so American
was just like good luck yeah they can't
do nothing what is she realistically
looking for just a refund yeah oh no
don't even give it to her because she
doesn't feel like what she was subjected
to was fair for what everybody else like
they're all paying the same amount for
you know it's just a default experience
yeah I think that she thinks she had to
go through something special that she
did go through something special but I
think like everybody goes through
special bad luck when they have bad luck
yeah exactly and those other girls are
probably uncomfortable too with her
sitting there yeah yeah but what about
babies crying you can't like complain
that you can't make the parents pay for
that dude flying sucks no matter what
yeah yeah like like if you have the
money to sit in a nice you know night a
first class or business class private
yeah yeah like if you have the money do
that then yeah go for it but then
sometimes you just you just have to like
do they have a clock economy class
come on when you buy plane tickets is
there a clause that says hey by the way
you know you're not gonna get a refund
if you end up sitting next to you know
fat people say you can yeah say it
oh what a dick
come on man no but seriously like do
they have a closet there where it's like
no they can't you're uncomfortable on
the plane but it's like sorry we can't
do anything about it you're not gonna
get refund I think I think it's more so
they'll just write non-refundable ticket
you know what I mean yeah like for any
manner of whatever they're not gonna
write like all XYZ reasons why you might
want to refund it it's just
non-refundable this is uh I looked up a
picture of her the um Pastor that was
sandwiched between it was a really funny
oh she's a pastor no she's a passenger
she's a pastor I was like what that
changed your opinion no I just I just
thought it was an interesting detail
this is a really funny photo it's no
longer just my chance she happens to be
sitting like this but this is her dude
she's annoying I swear she I Can Tell
She's annoying
yeah Kevin said it it's true bro is that
actually has a doctorate my good sir in
what
all the politics political science maybe
well obviously how did this photo pop up
I just searched her name that's just it
looks like someone that would complain
but I don't think that's her you don't
think it's her that's a Russian model
dude yeah I swear this is her dessert
that's from like uh hey would you like
to meet yeah that's her name Dr Sydney
Watson but look how many different
Sydney watches what what kind of dog
that's the one from the uh maybe it is
an article look uh okay who is Dr C
wants me American Airlines issues
response is obese oh yeah yeah that's
her oh so what did they say to her good
luck I'm sorry oh yeah the good luck all
right I said good luck but I wonder if
they actually said something but she
didn't like the response so she's taking
it like they said [ __ ] off you know the
crazy thing is like
anytime I get really really heated and
angry about because that's some pet
peeve [ __ ] right anything with the
airport when they like [ __ ] can't see
or fly you did this blah blah it puts
you at such a weird inconvenience as a
human being you're uncomfortable you're
sweating you're in public you got to
wait another 12 hours in some random
place you weren't expecting to they they
throw you in some shitty ass Hotel
because they did something wrong or over
but you know what I mean anytime you get
really really pissed about that
literally nothing ever positive like
nothing happens yeah and the best way to
get over it is to get over it and move
on you know master your mind yeah you
just have to move on because you're not
gonna win that one you know at least a
plane landed exactly at least you're
alive
if it were to crash problem with my
helicopter too
that's [ __ ] up man
what the [ __ ] I bounced off Alex I bet
you anything you felt hella safe during
that other fight nah dude he was smelly
and [ __ ] bro like but it was also like
hygiene is a difference what are you
gonna do like what am I gonna tell this
guy hey you should [ __ ] it you're gonna
smell like [ __ ] like with me it's like
if you're gonna go flying this is stuff
that can happen yeah complain about it
right yeah it's like be on the bus even
if you paid for it yeah so here's what
here's what the you were asking what the
airline said they said our passengers
come in all different sizes and shapes
we're sorry you were uncomfortable on
your flight that's all they need to say
and then and especially if she looks
like that no offense to her you know
like a little skinny chick of course she
would go on this tirade about like fat
people and [ __ ] it's like all right bro
you don't have to do all that she's not
just anybody who's she she has a YouTube
channel 763
000 subscribers she's a right-wing
critical commentator
yeah it's part of our talking points you
know I get it of course you don't want
to be in that situation but she's also
born into a conservative family in
Australia so maybe she's not as used to
dealing with the American way yeah
definitely on American Airlines that's
what the American way is you know kind
of Just Go With It yeah yeah but I feel
like like what you said you kind of just
have to go with I remember when I was
flying Arizona I tried to book the the
earliest flight it was like at six a.m
and when they were bringing our plane to
like the spot where they connected it
hit another plane sure I don't know it
was all over the news I don't know if
you guys saw it but that was the plane I
was supposed to be on oh so they crashed
into another plane and like the wing
broke and they were like oh it might be
like 30 minutes delay so we're sitting
there and then at like two hours passed
they're like yeah you guys are gonna
have to just book another flight and
that was it they just dipped and they
were like oh so like what do we do we're
like oh go on the site do it we have
another plane so we have to start
boarding the other people so we were
kind of just like left with like go
[ __ ] figure it out yourself but it's
like and like I said in my head I'm like
ah this is the [ __ ] that you have to
expect there's so much stuff going on
that I'm just like whatever oh I got a
good one I was coming back from
Guadalajara on Viva aerobus right and I
think that's like the the Mexican
version of like Southwest or something
all right or maybe spirit I don't know
um it's a big difference yeah a big
difference right
um and it was like 3am flight
we didn't sleep all night
I get I I finally fall asleep on the
plane and I'm sitting next to my buddy
and this you know larger woman it's a
Mexican woman she was very nice though I
finally fall asleep on the flight I wake
up to hot coffee
all over my belly dude she spilled on
accident she spit on accident she was
getting a sandwich from her bag or was
it on purpose it could have been and
also I was getting bit by mosquitoes or
whatever yeah not a big deal but then I
spill hot like I just wake up and I just
feel like I'm just like this dude I got
burns on my stomach bro like I got
[ __ ] up but what was I gonna do it was
gonna be like I'm gonna [ __ ] sue you
lady I'm gonna assume you could you
could technically can I yeah oh dude 100
did I miss it did I miss did I fumble
the back you would win but I'm sure you
could soon you'd have to prove some kind
of injury for sure be easier if we were
in American Airlines because that's
American stuff I missed my opportunity
dude well uh did she apologize oh yeah
it was totally fine and she was really
sweet about it she was really sweet but
it was it was afterwards I was like dude
this is [ __ ] hilarious when she fell
asleep were you attempted to even the
score yeah I was kind of [ __ ] Diet
Coke
what if that was like her sweet moves
you know she's like oh this guy's real
hot because coffee sucks Pat in your
dick and stuff
she got my number for sure yeah she has
a 90s movie approach it's a little
Senora you know he was very sweet very
sweet
[Music]